getrieben wir sehen sie der nächsten
folge wieder meine damen und herren
lassen
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft war mit kinos lucia
wunderschöne wir haben uns in dieser
folge jetzt mal wieder ein wenig
gedanken gemacht so wie wir das immer
machen wir schreiben uns natürlich
selbstverständlich tagtäglich
nachrichten war dieses projekt das dass
das frauen machen sich das macht mir
wirklich des halters link links und
wieso abends doch viel mühe mit
und so weiter und so fort aber es ist so
dass und ich möchte kurz erklären was
ich tue ich achte auf eure kommentare
und mir wurde geschrieben ich kann ja
mal einen bogen mit stärker einfach
verzaubern ja und dann habe ich von
meiner jugend am besten
ich mache das macht ja auch mal ein
kleiner kleiner schlossplatz wo es ein
bisschen
manche haben auch in die kommentare
geschrieben das wir ja keine mehreren
projektes haben dürfen und ich voller
hektik cook alle folgen durch aber der
luga mann der hat einfach immer alle
kisten kaputt gemacht mit unseren
vorherigen schildern
also das heißt fc kaputt gemacht haben
genau hier denke ich etwas verstört weil
sie es einfach alles super regelkonform
und es läuft einfach am laufenden band
wie tante berlin das läuft einfach so
geil
also ich hätte nie gedacht dass das hier
so gut wie nicht mehr nämlich dass das
betont jeder folge loben wir uns
inzwischen selbst es ist so super wie
das läuft es ist nicht zu fassen was wir
alles gelassen haben da ist übrigens ein
bogen drin da ist zweifellos habe ich es
lag blöcke die besetzt werden teilweise
nicht gesetzt
funktioniert alles das könnte dann
irgendwie an meiner wenigkeit liegen ich
weiß es ja nicht also ich mache von
links im hintergrund bleibt jetzt mal
nix im hintergrund runter ausnahmsweise
die zumal nichts im hintergrund hat ja
verständlich du kleiner kleiner
schlawiner ich holte mir einfach ich
kenne zehnmal für die fassade hoch krass
ist ja der tod von manuell von broken
fans kam die mittlerweile schon sagen
ist ja schon online deshalb mit astro
hsv hat jetzt hier die rinne ich
erinnere mich ja ja aber ich hab' ich
hab's nicht mehr so gut im kopf gehabt
allerdings auch gar nicht was ich was
ich genau macht aber irgendwas mache ich
gerade
ich kannte ich muss erstmal wieder
spinnen töten gehen um mir im bogen
anzug und ihr müsst in dieser episode
auch schon wieder umziehen
ja wir haben uns mit ziemlich gesagt wir
gehen jetzt einfach zwölf folgen 82
folgen zwölf minuten meinen ja und aber
ich finde von allen seiten abgeschossen
und anhalt ich dir kurz auf den boden
fertig mal warum soll ich dann halte ich
an all die netten menschen die was
wollen dann all die netten menschen hier
von wegen ja ich würde ja sagen dass das
das also wie diese umzieht hat die kommt
ja tatsächlich vom luca di hat er ja
großteils entworfen und sie trägt ja
früchte weil er den keller findet uns
keiner joints nach mali dabei das
schönste eine sache ist halt der liebe
early bei der ja schon
sehr erfreut darüber war das team das
eisenstück hat jetzt eine krasse tnt
falle gebaut
auch sehr schön vivaro news zitiert hat
also es gibt es eine wartung news
twitter profil die man einfach mit einer
ganzen folge eine bates in der alten
basis von chaos und kontrolle
das war das war schon richtig ich habe
mich so beendet als ich das gelesen habe
das war so witzig also ist natürlich ist
natürlich nicht böse gemeint ist
nachweislich aber es ist es war einfach
war einfach schon damals echt so cool
hier kombiniert man es dazu geschwemmte
ja ich bin auch schon auf der suche nach
spinnen für dich aber ich glaub ich
fange einfach gleich hier in strip
mining system an weil dann ist okay
irgendwo so ich bin ich im blick haben
auch schon so ein bisschen draußen ich
habe die tür übrigens hat offen gelassen
aber wir ziehen an
wir gehen da wir gehen strukturieren
leute ihr wisst ja ihr dürft von uns
nicht erwarten aber bei der nichts
erwartet bekommt ja auch im regelfall
viel stimmt nicht was du meinst aber ja
toll toll dass du mal wieder den wird
ist aufgefallen dass fällt einfach nie
zu ich sagte nein dafür bin ich zu und
wir machen auch einfach komplett
unterschiedliche sachen aber genau das
ist eigentlich ganz gut und das spricht
für unseren erfolg wird ja ja das stimmt
und stimmt ein gegner riesige schlucht
gefunden alter vater alter ich bin auf 5
hertz down halter ist das übel hier
luisa soll witzig ist witzig jetzt
wieder ein bisschen besser bvb war es
okay ich konzentriere mich ganz
entspannt im kohle mit kinos die
erfahrungen ja ja ich mache hat
erfahrung durch monster schnitzel ich
bringe gerade einfach herum was ist das
für einer
dazu sieht aus wie thaddeus was ich zum
wie thaddeus war da was
du bist auch grad am main nee ich bin
kein monster töten weil ich doch für
dich spinnenfäden sucht einen schönen
bogen machen du ich dachte mich gerade
dass wir beide in dieser folge einfach
complete meinen gehen soll ich einfach
mal richtig viel eisen mit dem oder
brauchen wir das überhaupt noch ich habe
hier schon wieder von 26
reisen ist eigentlich nie ist unnötiger
höchstens um die rüstung auf dem hohen
stand zu bekommen aber ansonsten
brauchen wir das eigentlich nichts und
diese summe von hohen stand bekommen was
man damit also wir wir werden ja nicht
so schnell fulda wirst du kriegen
deswegen könnten wir dass wir allmählich
auf schutz verzaubern das ist das
einzige was geht was ich mir nämlich
auch überlegt hat bezogen auf rüstung
mit dass eventuell wenn wir diamanten
haben und dann so viel jammern haben
dass wir die halt für rüstung ausgeben
das wir gesagt wir gehen jetzt komplett
aufrüstung dass wir komplett die rüstung
haben die sache ist halt ich wäre dafür
dass wir uns zum beispiel nicht bei den
brustpanzer machen sondern dass du dir
am besten in der hell macht nicht mit
einem brustpanzer also ganz einfach weil
ganz pessimistisch gesehen wenn einer
von uns beiden stimmt aus irgend einem
grund irgendwie in wasser ertrinken also
kann sich die andere die rüstung jemand
hätte dann wenigstens voller rüstung
reise ja ja das stimmt so ich hab dir
jetzt ich hab jetzt die die haltung
harry shearer nicht zu doch ich hab doch
gesagt ja das stimmt
typischer kommentar ja stimmt ja und ich
habe es gemacht
ich bin nicht am strip main und ich find
sie viel schneller als du
ist doch einfach spitze das war david
ist konkreter da findet er in zwei
freuen
es ist nicht zu fassen was ich für ein
profi hat mittlerweile beide gleich viel
diamanten gefunden würde ich mal sagen
ich habe eine letzte folge zehn stück
auf nach jetzt kann irgendjemand
nachzählen das ist der crafter der wird
aber auch ganz schön schnell hier
wir loben uns einfach in jeder folge
selbst wenn ich dass ich hier ruhig ich
fand mich verzaubert hier in bogen für
dich ja mit mit mit liebe und du bist
hier bis zu eur ist eine drauf die
verzauberung nie bereist da ist liebe
drauf wie viel erfahrung kostet so
bitteschön ich hab meine meine erfahrung
geht für deine bögen drauf mein freund
natürlich jetzt aber mal will ich jetzt
mal ganz klar betonen hier sind so viele
diamanten so vieles schon wieder
gefunden
es würde ich die größte [ __ ] dies
überhaupt in ganz ding gibt denn ganz
ding so ja also ein bogen ist fertig
kannst du dir oben in der truhe abholen
der branche
schon scheiße übel ja sehr stark ich
habe hier zehn diamanten wieder im
inventar freue ich mich schon wieder die
abreise langweile linien in meinem ich
kontakt jaxx tschuldigung mal dass ich
einfach niemals was weiß was ich mir
jetzt mal sind wir manchmal mit diamant
schuhe bis ich mache mir ich mache mir
jetzt einfach du kannst nichts ich habe
aber schon schlief auf stufe 2 sage ich
du mich mal mit nein
sollte eigentlich brustpanzer machen
wenn dann hast du schon brustpanzer aus
diamanten
ich hab das handy am anstieg wie viel
hast du wieviel hast du grad gefunden
andreas also ich habe jetzt in einem
inventar gerade 10 uhr zu rechnen und
braucht ab stück dann kann ich mir
bewusst manchmal mehr ausgerechnet dass
wir insgesamt 24 glaub ich glaub ich hab
noch zwölf jahren kann ich mit
brustpanzer machen ist die erlaubnis
gegeben
ja klar kannst du machen der mit mach
ich mit meinen zähnen auch in boston
bleibt weil man weil man brustpanzer ist
nämlich bisher sehr sehr scheiße und
deswegen bei super das toll gemacht mit
dem brustpanzer hab ich klasse habe ich
den kräften und zack dia brustpanzer und
natürlich auch gleich mal das recht so
schön es läuft wirklich bei uns also
wiederholen gott sei dank ist es auf der
brust bands ist auch schützen nicht auch
irgendwie so eine scheiße wie wie sonst
was jetzt bin ich aber sehr sehr
glücklich warum habe ich denn jetzt hier
auf wir haben so viele verzauberte also
bist du noch da drin das ist schon gar
nicht mehr feierlich
so also sind noch vier diamanten oben da
bediente dich einfach wieder lust daran
hast dass du bist du ja nicht an ich hab
hier zehn dazu nicht gehen dann habe ich
fehler mache ich mir einen brustpanzer
helm ja genau macht das so ich gehe ich
gehe mal raus jetzt woanders an mit dem
strip main oder oder wie viel haben aber
noch genug zeit gut tut gut das wir
haben gerade sind bei acht minuten 30
ich habe scheiße scheiße scheiße war
richtig scheiße weiß was da draußen ist
weiß was da draußen ist weil das ist
eine echte wende dich an greift dann
bringt er nicht mit einem trank runter
auf auf ein herz die bringt mich runter
auf ein herz mit dem kranken alten
versteck dich irgendwann bitte das ist
nicht normal das ist nicht mehr normal
warum warum trägst du drin angreifen
nein ich kann die nach dem 9
ich glaube sie an dicht über dem boden
ob sie getötet ich habe sie getötet
alles easy brown starb der junge
ich war draußen und hat mir direkt lesen
ihres einem verzauberten bogen ins geld
die hat mir die hat mir das in die
fresse geworfene also den den den trank
und nicht getroffen weil so wie ich das
in der folge von den und der bergmann
mal gesagt dass sie die mega abgetastet
von wegen jahre mal zu gewinnen wenn
dich das trifft du bist direkt halber
marsch und also ich hatte gerade einfach
nur babbel des todes des todes na gut
ich finde eine hürde nach der anderen
ja das gut das ist gut du hast das du
machst das superliga danke schön dass du
heute stellvertretend produktiv ist ja
du kein ding du hast ja auch
mittlerweile auch schon gemacht ich habe
keinen ich habe keine fackeln werden
soll wo will ich will ich meinen gehen
weil ich gucke mal mit die koordinaten
ich jetzt nicht wieder draußen kann ich
glaube ich begebe mich hat man da
draußen ich mach uns gleich schon mal
hier eine neue basis okay in so einem in
so einem in seinem bereich wo weil ich
habe ihr erklärt dass es besser ist wenn
wir hier unten irgendwo rangehen
weil wir dann gleich auf eine gewisse
tiefe sind so deswegen eine gewisse
ergebnis auf jeden fall die museen sind
es die bisher 21 das ist conny spruch es
ist kann kräftig hatte ich habe immer
echt so angst ich hab nicht um mich
selbst aber ich habe einfach so angst
dass ich falls ihr nicht verbindung ist
gerade im gestorben ja tut mir leid das
ist halt einfach irgendwie stetiger
alles beim weiße weiße weiße weiße wie
süß das gerade eben war und dann einfach
nicht richtig verstanden
bis auf außer dass ich dich verliere
richtig so richtig richtig swisspro sein
können wie komme ich denn hier zurück
von wo komme ich denn ich weiß noch gar
nicht was ich gerade mache ich bei uns
gerade neue base schon mal aus weil der
handwerker müssen wir dann müssen wir
nur umziehen
das ist doch ist doch schon mal was kann
ja gut ich bin geht nicht nach hause ich
muss jetzt quasi nur noch laufen
okay dass man mal so ich lass dich lass
dich gleich ich komme gleich raus
sondern lohnt sich die ich mache gar
schon mal nur unsere unsere vor räume
fertig ich weiß die folgen natürlich
nicht ganz so hart am main aber das habe
ich dem von ihnen bogen
zusammengebastelt eine hexe getötet und
bin ich von ihr töten lassen das so cool
cool cool cool
und ich habe auch zum inventar und
daraus mache ich mir jetzt noch 440
woche 8 für einen brustpanzer und ich
brauche fünf vor allen helden
deswegen braucht ja nur noch eine
diamant hose dann sind wir glaube ich
die beste ausgerüstet
damit werde nur noch nie verzaubern oder
einfach ziemlich überzogen eigentlich
schon verzaubert kinos der bogen ist ein
bogen drin da hat stärke 2 da ist
verzaubert das ist ja wundervoll
das hab ich gedacht ich bin so grad auf
höhe 70 hier wieder bin jetzt in unserer
basis wieder und dann will ich sagen
kann ich mir schon was in den tag voll
mit den wichtigsten und zucker bisschen
gewachsen
ich komm ich komme gleich rum ja und
dann kann man ja ich mache das ebit bei
gang für uns und wir uns auch dazu
entschieden sobald wieder mal wirklich
irgend ein halbwegs anständig
ausgerüstet sind wenn irgendwelche
unschuldig schuldig und schuldiger wir
sind silberfische das heißt es sind dann
schon in der nähe was auch oder ist das
doch dann schien den eben silberfische
das ist oder auch nicht dass das der
fall ist oder so was ist das denn tiger
viele silberfische mega viele die genau
richtig hier ich brauch nur noch einen
halben alter hits punktlos ich war nur
noch einen halben schutz.de und ganzen
aber hier sind
was geht denn hier ab die idee ist
einfach mal wenn jemand brustpanzer
jesse schutz drauf und auf meinen jemand
helm ist ihr schuss sicher irgendwas
hier sind dann wahrscheinlich irgendwo
noch mehr silberfische oder federvieh
müssen uns ja ich komme ja ich komme ich
komm ich komm ich komm ich lasse dich
keine sorge ich bin schon vor dem spiel
so so ich habe eine kleine fackeln
gestellt wenn wir das wieder finden
warte ich komme ich hier schnell hoch
gesprungen bisschen beeilen
ich habe das gesagt sie auch den den
umzug in bekommen wir haben fünf minuten
wenn das ausreizen das gut so jetzt war
das hallo hallo hallo hallo hallo guck
mal hier
du siehst meinen namen siehst du meinen
namen nicht ich will mich jetzt auch
gerade irgendwie lieber damit
beschäftigen dass wir uns nicht noch ein
strike bekommen ja ich sag doch ich sagt
auch hier ich bin doch schon am start
ich pack schon packt schon zeug ein
ich bin schon ich bin schon dran ich mag
schon alles ein was ge andere kiste mit
mir nicht in den höfen ist glaube ich
auch nichts mehr drin
ok ok ok dann lasst uns jetzt mal lasst
uns jetzt mal direkt kommst du mir nach
doch in der in der kiste ist auch noch
enorm viel drin in der ein hier das
heißt da muss ich auch noch mitnehmen
komme ich immer die die stärksten sachen
mit die wichtigsten und irgendwie den
den den schrott des jahrhunderts ich
glaube schon mal und macht hier
irgendwie ne allerdings dass wir
irgendwo rum ziehen
also komm komm ich zeig dir bewusst ist
und dann holt er gleich noch mehr bist
du bist du draußen guck mal hier
probiert hast noch ein bisschen mehr
sein in der kiste ins emmental komcom
ist gar nicht mal wiederkommen
außerdem haben die kraft uns erst einmal
um ja dass ich ein bisschen will ich
noch gerne mitnehmen ist so glaube ich
noch ein paar bücher drin gewesen und
rüstung nicht dass sich irgendjemand
anders der halt mega schlecht
ausgerüstet ist oder die guck mal da und
wo die fackel ist wieso es ja nach das
heißt schon alt und mit zehn minuten
alle drei minuten zeit das müsste
eigentlich alles alles aus wie haben die
zeit
aber das ist ja wunderschön ob diese
form der fake raum und das ist die
richtige
das ist so stark dass wir einfach immer
so wir denken wirklich an alles hast du
gestern aber ja dass in spa bei crafting
table das ist natürlich super hast du
hast dich los mit dir so kurzak alles da
alles rein alles rein aber mal alles
random reinpacken außerdem vielleicht
die ball zu kämpfen
alles reine ordnungsrahmen als das dass
das stau ist auch wenn wir unseren
chanten table da drin haben selbst wenn
jemand unsere basis finden würde ja dann
wäre es ja wer's trotzdem so weit so
dass er den schalthebel auf der glaube
ich abbauen aber wenn wir nicht reden da
der geschissen
weil es gibt ja ich weiß gibt es auch
welche die noch kein star portable haben
ich weiß es nicht ich weiß dass
mittlerweile auch nicht ich bin fehler
den punkt ich weiß so dass selbst und
spark sehr krass von der brüstung
ausgerüstet sind
aber ich habe auch noch erhalten sind dr
mir fehlt etwas mega sinnvoll wäre wenn
die basis niemand entdeckt wenn wir die
in unserer alten basis einfach zu tnt
fallen rheinbogen würden das müssten
quasi hier an unsere basis
das kann ja in der nächsten folge machen
wir machen quasi hier so eine fackel
dran weiß ja es ist richtig erkennt und
dann ist das auch ein bisschen nicht so
offensichtlich dass wir auf jeden fall
ein star
das war hier das ab so kannst du dir so
eine axt dabei dass du das abbauen
kannst ja klar
dann macht das niemand das schild mit
und ich rede da schnell zurück in die
basis und dann sollte das alles
hoffentlich was sind buch genannten 34
sind perfekte derzeit okay okay das ist
supertoll gewaltig habe diamanten
gefunden ich hab nur noch eine halbe
rüstungs punkt der mir fehlt das ist
richtig gut und das hat nix gemacht aber
das hat er gut gemacht ich hab dir einen
bogen gebaut
mike freund hast du uns viele andere
lustige dinge getan weil das dadurch
einen stein darüber kommt ich hab meine
meine sachen verzaubert ich war ziemlich
cool ich muss geraten viele steine nein
wären da kein kind sondern bekommt auch
er davor machen dabei erde am anfang das
merkt man dann bringt der vorraum aber
nix warum weil die dänen mit steinen
es ist ja ich habe aber gerade keine
durch absteiger richtigen oder mache ich
hier den mache ich hier den vorraum zu
jahr
wir müssen jedoch noch ein schild dran
bauen alter das ist das wichtigste
ja macht dass hass und schilder ich hab
kein holz ich hab dich doch da kannst du
kannst du machen bist du dran bist dran
ja wenn dabei so grant ist 83 sekunden
auf
ich würde darauf geschrieben ja so gut
wir sehen in der nächsten folge wieder
meine damen und herren endlich gefallen
lassen bewährt und damit ins bei mir
alles gut